Now, we talked earlier in this lecture about kind
of the, the basic approaches to Scaling. We said, the
first one was optimize the code. And when we're
talking about a database we're probably not optimizing code but
this, this was, this stage of thinking means, you
know, have the appropriate indexes. You know, make sure the
query is sane. You know, make sure you're only querying
for things that you actually need. If the query's simple,
and all those types of things. We're not going to do that here,
because our query is actually very simple, and Google App Engine makes our
indices for us. But this is always the first thing you want to
check. If the index App Engine makes isn't optimal for the query you're
running, you may have to make something by hand. You should always start
here. You know, the first step is limit the work the database needs
to do in the worst case. Let's assume we've already done that, because
we have, for ASCII chan. Something else
we talked about was, adding more machines.
We don't really have control over that, in this particular situation
App Engine manages that for us. If you're not using App Engine,
maybe you need to add more machines. Maybe you need to start
doing replication, or sharding, or those techniques. Now, if you've ever tried
to do those techniques on your own you know, that they're very
difficult, they're very complex. An this is usually, adding more machines when
you're talking about a database, is kind of the last resort for
scaling. Something else we talked about was using big machines again we
don't have a whole lot of control over that in App Engine. I
think you can upgrade machines a little bit but, you know, let's, let's
say we're, we're, we're done messing with that, or maybe we're tired of
paying for database queries, an we just want to get to the, the fun part.
The, what we're going to spend this lecture talking about, we' re just cache
it. A very simple thing we can do after we've optimized the database,
and we don't want to fiddle with more system administration is Cache this query.
You know in ASCIIchan the front page
of ASCIIchan only changes when somebody submits.
So that means it's a good opportunity to Cache what we
actually store. And that is what I'm going to do right now,
is add a little bit of Cache to ASCIIchan. Okay, you
all remember ASCIIchan, it's online at ASCIIchan.com. You remember how it works
we can type in a title and then we can draw
some ASCII art or in my case Paste it. And when
you submit the art you see a listing of all the
previous arts submitted to ASCIIChan. The way this works in the code,
when you do a get on ASCIIChan, when you call
this function called render_front, which is defined here. Okay, so this
render_front function, basically, what it does is it runs this
data star query, written in Gql, that looks up the ten
most recent pieces of art. So limit ten, that's how
we know we're looking up ten. Order by created descending, so
that orders them by the time they were created. This
where ancestor equals art key is a data store technique for
basically insuring your query is consistent. I kind of wanted to talk
about that in unit 3 but things seem to be getting a
little complex. If you read the data store docs you, and kind
of search for the word consistent, you will see what this technique is
referring to so anyway not super important for our purposes so you
know why that's there, it's not required. If I got rid of this
at our scale, this site would behave exactly the same. So then
what we do is we actually run that query, remember, this just defines
the query. When you iterate over the query, or in my
case turn it into a list, that's when you actually go
to the database and, and get the results back. Remember I
turn it into a list here so that I don't accidently run
the query twice when I iterate over it again here, and
then again when we actually render the page. I just want to
run the query once. So, what we want to do is cache
this query because our front page isn't going to change very often. Most
Users come to ASCIIChen and just look at the front page.
We don't need to hit the database over, and over, and
over again every time a user does that. That's just going to
cost us money, you know, waste Google's resources, and generally just make
the world a worst place, so. First thing I'm going to do,
is I'm going to pull out this piece of code into it's
own function so it's a little easier to manage. Okay, I'm
going to call this function Top arts. It's not going to take any parameters
because we're just returning we know what the query's going to be,
the query's going to be the same every time. Okay so all I've
done is I've created this function top_arts and I copied this code.
Actually I cut this code from render_front and moved it into this
function and then we we make the query, we run the
query, and then we return the result. And then in render front,
we just call the top arts function, so everything should behave as
it did before. We can go ahead and give that a test.
Here's a front page with our art, and if I were to
reload this page, we see that nothing's changed. So, nothing big there,
we didn't expect anything to change, and nothing did, okay? So let's
go back to the code and start making our improvements. Now, one thing
we're going to want to do is we want to have a way
of telling ourselves when we're actually running this query so we can actually
test to make sure our code is working. Now I am not
a Google App Engine pro, but I am going to add a little
statement like this. Login.error and we will say that this
db query. This will print in our error console, the string
db query. Now normally you should use login.debug for this
purpose. But the debug mode in app engine is driving me
nuts right now. So, this'll be a little bit easier
for me to demonstrate. I'm going to have to also import the
logging module for this to work. I'll go ahead and do
that, just import logging. So, this should print in the console,
every time we run a DB query. And let's see if that
works. So, here is ASCIIchan and I am going to hit reload on
this page and I am going to go to the terminal, and you
can see that I am printing error and DB query that is my
string and we can also see the browser fetched slash which is the
actual request to asciichan, and also the request of favicon since I haven't
created it. Just 404s. So now we have this printing and we can
see that everytime I reload the page in the browser and we get
these lines again and I see we get the words DB Query, right
before the request. What we want to do is we want to get rid of
these words without just commenting out
the logging statement. Okay, so let's add
some caching and we're going to use the same algorithm that we used on that
quiz that, that you guys just
implemented. We're going to create a dictionary and
we're going to call it cache. Now, we have to have a key to cache,
I usually like to store my keys in a variable. In this case
I'm just going to call the key Top. This is how we're going to store the,
how we're going to reference the result of this query
in our cache. And then I'm just going to change we're
just going to rewrite this function to use the caching
algorithm. So if key in cache, arts equals CACH key.
Else, we want to run our query. So, we run
our query in the out statement and of course we
want to store the result of our query in
the cache. And then we return our arts. Okay, so,
pretty simple change. Now we're caching the result of this one query.
Let's see if it works, we go to our browser, I hit
reload. The page loads with no error, so that's good. And then
I go to my console and I see that it printed out
DB QUERY, and has the results. Now if I were to reload
this page again again, no error. And I go back to the
console, and I can see that we made a, a second request.
Here it is, GET slash, but this time there's no DB QUERY. So
if I were to go to our front page and hit Reload
Trust me that I'm doing it. You can kind of see it
blinking a little bit over and over again and then, I go
back to the console, I can see a bunch of requests that
note, DB queries. That's pretty cool, huh? So now our front page
is a lot faster, let's submit a new piece of art to
ASCIIchan here, or at least, my local ASCIIChan. It's going to be a
picture of beer, looks like it's from Hofbra House. I click submit,
huh my beer did not appear I still have
my original art from before. What do you think happened.